they 12 on the general election campaign
i'm here at Charing Cross station
passengers commuters filtering in from
the south coast plenty of marginal seats
along the train tracks and finally could
it be a case of fair's fair for
hard-pressed commuters facing the
highest train prices in Europe the
Conservatives are promising a freeze on
rail fares in real terms for five years
which will go down well with commuters
in these important modules no doubt
about it but it's an important
philosophical shift five years ago the
planning is spending with you mr.
increase fares by inflation plus three
percent and they've gone up twenty
percent join the coalition there was a
philosophy behind this that the taxpayer
should pay less and the passenger should
pay more the user pays that has gone out
of the window with this announcement and
could be seen as a strategic victory to
that cost of living agenda championed by
Ed Miliband but a version a conservative
version of that agenda that state wealth